so also why you're an amazing human is I
recently heard that you love um
journaling I'm a huge Journal kid now I
get a little nervous about someone
finding it but I know yeah cuz that's
happened to me before someone found it
and like read it and then accused me of
like what was in it I was like you got
my that's my mess I was like wait what I
was like you jumped in that tornado
that's on you like yeah but like I love
it though it makes me feel good to get
it out yeah it kind of it's yeah another
thing it's you know Chang your change
will change your life I started waking
up an hour and a half to two hours
before my wife and my kids and see your
VI time yes my me time yeah I Journal I
do my yoga I drink my coffee and stuff
and it's it's a chance for me to find
out where I am and uh before the day
starts rushing in and i' you know I've
had realizations for for the record you
know I I went through one of those
really tough Seasons that's kind of
waiting for everybody you know if you
haven't been through it yet just wait is
coming you know but you know one of
those seasons and I Journal through the
whole thing and I really was just
honestly trying to make it to the other
side of that yeah and I I never was um
thinking that I would use it creatively
in any way but yeah it dawned on me uh
this one day as I was listening to music
and you know music was such a balm and
such a um Guiding Light that time it was
like oh I'm supposed to use this I'm
supposed to write about this you know
I'm supposed to make the record that I
needed to listen to you know about going
through you mind if I tag into the
journaling conversation yes do you
Journal I do I I say this in the special
you you just played a cliff but I I find
if you write down every few nights what
you're saddest about or angriest about
you can start to see your own life as a
story and when you see your own life as
a story sometimes you can zoom out and
encourage the main character to make
better decisions wow
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home